wandering off on the hiking trail seemed
like a great way to get in touch with
Mother Nature but now every part of the
forest is starting to look the same and
you're not sure which direction you came
from you try to get your bearings by
checking your phone but the battery's
dead so what do you do now you're lost
and completely off the grid here's how
to survive alone in a forest it's very
easy to get lost in a forest everything
looks the same so it's hard to keep
track of visual landmarks and it's
nearly impossible to see any distant
destinations beyond the trees so instead
of focusing on finding your way out of
the forest you're probably better off
figuring out how to survive until
someone finds you how could you make a
fire without a lighter or matches would
you be better off eating plants or bugs
and how could you use pine needles to
help you get rescued
[Music]
step 1 find freshwater if you're going
to last out here for a long period of
time you'll need to stay hydrated keep
an eye out for animals animal tracks
green foliage mosquitoes and flies as
they're all good signs that water is
nearby in the forest you're most likely
to find the creek a stream or a pond
another way to stay hydrated is to save
rainwater if you have anything that will
hold water leave it out to collect rain
or Dew if you don't have any containers
use a tarp or a poncho or if you have
one hang them by tying the corners to
trees three to four feet off the ground
put a small rock in the middle of the
material to make a kind of bowl to
collect the water step to build a
shelter the canopy of trees above will
provide decent shelter from the Sun but
if you're going to be stuck here for a
long time you're going to want something
better the easiest most effective way to
protect yourself from the elements would
be to build a lean-to shelter to do this
you'll need to find a large branch and
lean one end against a tree then place
smaller branches at 45-degree angles
along the length of the large branch and
cover the entire structure with leaves
and foliage step 3 find food
all that shelter building is bound to
build up your appetite so you need to
start looking for something to eat
plants would seem to be the easiest bed
but you have to be careful because a lot
of them are poisonous some
characteristics of poisonous plants to
watch out for include white or yellow
berries thorns mushrooms and
umbrella-shaped flowers so unless you
have a guidebook on which plants are
edible it's best to play it safe and not
eat any at all
instead you can flip over logs to find
easy to catch protein filled insects you
can safely eat worms ants and
grasshoppers mmm but avoid spiders ticks
and flies and just to be safe you should
probably cook any insects before you eat
them but you can't do that without heat
step 4
make a fire if you have a lighter or
matches on you then this shouldn't be
too hard start by collecting everything
you're going to burn dry leaves or tree
bark are easy to burn so light them
first build a little teepee with the
tinder and kindling tinder will be the
first thing that catches a spark it then
transfers the sparks to the kindling and
starts a flame but if you don't have a
lighter you'll need to get a little more
creative
make a fire plough to ignite the fire by
scraping a small groove in the middle of
a flat piece of wood then create
friction by quickly plowing up and down
the groove with a small twig until it
produces an ember step 5
get rescued
yeah this is easier said than done but
you've got to be proactive about it stay
where you are
that way rescuers won't be able to find
you much easier than if you hike around
if you have a mirror or some aluminum
foils you could use it to reflect light
to planes or other people to help them
find you another option would be to make
smoke signals with your fire glean
leaves and pine needles create a lot of
smoke so use those using a branch with
leaves on it
cover the fire for three to four seconds
to trap the smoke and then remove it
keep doing that so that it creates
clouds of smoke when you do finally get
rescued you're going to have some time
to think about how all this could have
been avoided next time don't wander off
the guided trail research the area
you're going to be exploring beforehand
and bring along some supplies in case
you do get disoriented in some areas you
might even want to prepare yourself to
defend against predators but don't worry
we've got just the video to help you
come out on top
[Music]
[Applause]